- On peut se rendre en Ontario
ou Doug Ford vient de remporter
un deuxième mandat majoritaire.
des troupes. Cette victoire
conservatrice n'est pas une
ampleur.
- Souvenez-vous en 2018 les
ontariens avaient voté contre 15
année ils ont voté massivement
pour d'autres formes. Il semble
être en bonne posture pour
2018. En ce moment les
progressif conservateur en 80
des circonscriptions où ils sont
en avance. En Ontario les
chiffres magiques pour unerrrrrr
124. Si on regarde la carte,
c'est vraiment un raz-de-maréeée
bleu auquel on a droit. Dans le
grand Toronto ou les
réussi à reprendre le comté de
Paimpol. Mais aussi dans le sud-
ouest il
à Windsor. Une circonscriptionda
remporté son siège c'est le
premier candidat conservateur à
faire 19
Victor pour les coour les coour.
Les militants beaucoupsiasme. De
chez lui.
Sans doute une autre ambiance
pour le NPD. La soirée est plus
difficile pour les libéraux.
Leur chef a été défait.
- Le NPD a quand même réussi à
officielle. Ils ont quitté
Queens Park avec 138 sièges.
Cette fois-ci il semble êtr Du u
côté libéral beaucoup plus
difficile. On semb
seulement neuf sièges d'acquis
après la déconfiture de 2018. Du
côté libéral qui va faire mal
c'est la de Steven de Steven del
deux canons sont comptés. Quelle
sera l'a
Andrea Horvath? C'est à voir.t e
ambiance de fête.assez survoltéd